Now back to Marla,
who already has four chronic diseases.
She developed diabetes 15 years ago,
and is now showing early signs of lung
problems, called chronic obstructive
pulmonary disease, or COPD for short.
In recent years, her blood
pressure has become elevated, and
she's also taking medications for that.
She was also recently diagnosed
with a heart problem,
called coronary artery disease,
and needs even more medications.
We already know one thing about
chronic diseases, they can't be cured.
Marla illustrates two other key points.
They are often caused by behavior.
Marla's obesity is caused
by her poor diet, rich and
processed foods with too
many calories from fats and
carbohydrates, combined with far
too little physical activity.
This weight gain contributed
to her developing diabetes and
high blood pressure.
Her lung disease was
caused by her smoking.
The second key point
about chronic diseases,
is they can cause other
chronic diseases.
Marla's diabetes and high blood pressure
contributed to the development of her
heart disease, and puts her at greater
risk for a heart attack, or stroke.
If her diabetes and high blood
pressure are not well controlled, she
could develop chronic kidney disease,
and other more serious problems.